make sure you guys give it thanks okay
because we really do appreciate it all
right all right Melissa and the kids yes
you're back yay we're here one more day
of life thank you Jesus yes you're
surviving I think we are I think uh the
my viewers donations to the GoFundMe
helped you guys a lot right very much
very much I thank all you guys for
everything you know we were able to buy
an RV we're able to have our little
space of our own you know we're very
grateful aren't we kids we're very
grateful yeah is it nice
we just have to do a little bit of
fixing up and they're like tearing out
the carpet and some other fixing up for
the RV but other than that um we're you
know
uh in and out of staying in the hotel
um even though I'm paying for it now but
we're in and out of there I'm trying to
get it to where uh the RV is stable
enough to go to Springfield where my
brother lives and he's running a company
out there and um you know just spend our
time right there because you know out
here it's getting a little bit you know
and I'd rather be you know where it's a
little bit more calmer even though
everywhere is you know we're in
Springfield uh Springfield it's
California yeah no it's far from here
yeah what state
um I haven't researched that but I know
he told me he was in Springfield though
but I told him I said before I get to
moving anywhere yeah I have to start
checking out everything because
um I don't want to just up and leave
like that you know what I'm saying I
have to prepare the RV I have to prepare
our stuff I have yeah things are going
well yeah yes your kids are in school
now oh the kids have always been in
school but what about yeah the last time
he was fighting they were home steady
yeah so you're teaching all four of
these kids yeah yeah and you've got dogs
yes yes we got dogs your life is chaos
it's always like that I mean I'm an
animal lover I've always rescued animals
all of our animals are rescue animals
you know I've always tried to take care
of them the best that I could you know
until I got into this situation you know
then I lowered down on helping animals
but I still got a few animals that I do
help we got rabbits we got lizards we
got Birds we got dogs Turtles and kids
these are other babies but like you know
I try to help everybody that I could
help you know you've got your hands full
yes yes
yeah so and pretty soon
pretty soon it's gonna be all of their
birthdays so she's nine she'll be ten
this one will be eight he'll be five and
she'll be turning three are all the
birthdays close oh yeah these two are
two days apart this is January she's on
the 14th and she well 15th and she's on
the 13th and this one is September 29th
and then she's December 14th oh you got
a bunches so they're just yeah yeah but
the most closest ones is these two and
she was mad my older my second to oldest
daughter she's like how could she be
born before me and I said she's not born
before you I said you're the oldest of
her you know but she's just born two
days after you I can't help it
but well it is what it is your kids are
so well behaved yeah
I would hope they are I try to teach
them a lot manners excuse me please
thank you you know if it's not yours
don't touch it ask for it you know
um be grateful for what you got you know
and just try to keep on pushing it
forward you know but I also do teach
them that you know you you can't
um
you can't always not like be responsible
you have to be responsible for
everything you know what I'm saying you
have to carry a good job you know what
I'm saying and carry yourself good that
way you get some more in life and you
don't have to be you know I mean
sometimes it doesn't matter you know you
could have a good job and then you could
drop you know but I'm just trying to
teach them you know just do things the
right way so you get things the right
way you know
that's great that's what I'm trying to
do you seem to be doing a great job with
these kids
I'm trying my best you know they still
argue trust me yeah forget it they argue
but you know
we'll see they're still all very young
you know
yeah two kids yeah yep especially acts
Elijah he dives off of stuff he jumps on
stuff who gives it who gives who gives
you the most trouble you the boy Let's
uh Point him this way
he's the most active one out of
everybody he's the most active out of
everybody you have to get him together
sit down
yeah you do you have to get them
together
so your plan is to
get your RV set up get out of town yeah
move to Springfield yeah wherever that
mystery Springfield is yeah well it's
Springfield you know what I'm saying
probably there's probably others yeah I
just have to research it I was just
talking with my brother last night you
know what I'm saying and I'm telling him
I want to come that way and he's just
telling me you know research everything
make sure you got everything in order
with the RV that it can make it and that
you have enough gas money you have
enough you know things fixed in the RV
that nothing breaks down on you you know
and because you don't want to come out
here and and be stranded in the middle
you know what I'm saying it's not like
he won't come and get us you know what
I'm saying but it's just that he wants
me to always research everything and
make sure that everything is in order
you know which I you know I'm I'm
preparing but like I said we just spoke
last night you know so he's been over
there for a while
but son get over here
it's nice that you have your your
brother and your uncle to help out yeah
yeah well I mean I do have other sisters
you know what I'm saying don't get me
wrong it's just that I didn't grow up
with them you know what I'm saying I
didn't grow up with none of them and my
brother like we spoke on and off and
some of my sisters we spoke on and off
like my sister that's in the Army we
spoke on and off and um like I just okay
you need to get off of that
so we spoke on and off and so like
you know I don't know like I did go at
one point to Georgia to visit one of my
sisters but it didn't um
like she wanted me to stay there but I
didn't want to stay there I didn't feel
comfortable you know what I'm saying NRV
will give you the freedom yeah yeah and
what my brother I could park my office
where my brother's living because he's
the owner you know
all right so so let's let's
let's let's meet your kids again
so who's who's who Santa
Elijah we know Elijah
Elijah say hi say hi Elijah
say hi he's telling you something come
on I think I think I know we'll get them
later
this is Elijah
yeah
this is Moody well if you could ever get
her your youngest Erica and Angie you
got hair on your face
tonight
I don't know what you guys did you got a
rough job
this is a mother's job all the time you
know like it's it's nothing new it's you
know leave that alone baby
all right I'll let you get back to you
you gotta do it you know
what could you do we're just very
grateful kids are you very grateful yeah
well tell them to say thank you for
everything that you've done for us
Moody said thank you
all right you guys I'm glad things are
going well yes thank you thank you guys
thank you for everything again God bless
all of you guys today any people want to
continue to donate this yeah
oh yes yes to get over there to my
brother and stay over there and
Springfield Wyoming yeah well well we'll
figure it out you know
it's on the map thank you Marissa thank
you kitties thank you guys bye